what kind of essentials do you put in
that guy
so glad you asked
hey what's up gq this young gunner and
i'm about to get into my tin essentials
my first essential would be my
custom-made bible
a bible is an essential of my life and
this happened to be
one of my favorite right here my best
friend mother made it for me
so she's like my second mom she gave it
to me for christmas
it has my artist name on it and
it's very special to me when i might be
like going through something
i kind of just read it and i kind of
like just let like
things find me and i just read it and
just kind of relax and
kind of ease me i always was like
came up from like a home of god where we
always pray we didn't have to go to
church
every sunday but we we knew to have a
relationship with god
my mom made sure that if just follow me
as i just grew
like every other day you know just
praying keep your relationship with god
my next essential would have to be this
louis vuitton blanket
feel that feel that
yeah soft i travel a lot so
instead of using like the plain covers i
like to bring my own
i like to be comfy so when i'm on the
road
the h is silent i love i love blankets
i think it's just something that stuck
with me like just having
blankets i also had a blanket growing up
it was a little blue blanket
it had spider-man on it i don't know
what happened to my spider-man blanket i
think i might have grew out of it
you know i had to probably replace it i
love blankets it cozy vibes
my next essential would have to be this
picture right here it's a picture of me
and my mom
when i first bought a house it makes me
think about one of the biggest perches i
ever
made and i got a chance to share that
with her we hardly ever took pictures
now we take a lap and it's like one of
the very first
like pictures that we like posted on
instagram and stuff like that
so it's just a picture that i cherish
and i just have to have
every day be on my screen say it means a
lot to me
my next essential would have to be my
hard drive
it's very very special and i'm very very
protective over this
i have the rugged drive with it like a
case over
and i also had another case that it sits
in
because i'm just very protective of this
this is like
half of my life it has all my music on
it i got a backup drive too so i ain't
crazy but i gotta have my drive it's one
of my most essentials
my next essential would have to be my
bags i'm a bag collector
keep bags i love bags
i'm about a bag i feel like i got to
keep it bad because i keep
all like the rest of my essentials in
there too also like my day-to-day stuff
i have to carry with me
just like necessities you know what i'm
saying as you can see this is a chrome
heart bag
very rare i bought it in vegas it's a
vegas edition chrome hearts
costs are bad i cherish it i like bags
i keep watches keep a few watches in up
just the day-to-day just to go with the
outfits
i got a white sky dweller with baguettes
in it i got a cardio watch
i've been bought this one of my first
watches i bought rolex for the blue face
i still have it i'm not letting it go
this is another watch plane jane
my management bought this for me i
cherish it's awesome
another essential condoms
[Music]
i'm a trojan man i got a low i've been
using
and six but yeah it's one of my
essentials though cause
we all need protection practice say sex
i
i advise it it's mandatory with me
it you know what i'm saying keep you
keep you a few
staying safe is an essential next
essential would have to be
money something you just gotta have you
know just
like tens and twenties and thirties and
forties it usually be a honey bun but
i've been spinning
uh this it's like thirty 000 maybe a
little over 30.
i barely use cash but i'd like to keep
it just in case it's just emergency cash
to have on you at all times
major purchases like big like big
purchases
i use my car i pay my taxes
and they good when you paying taxes when
you use your car i feel like it's better
to have cash in case your friends or
family need a few dollars you know
you got cash for play with it you can
shuffle it
i like i like to shuffle the money my
next
essential would have to be my car keys
i got a few car keys don't tend to bring
all of them out
this is four keys i got five cars
six cars the lamborghini yours the
2020 steam red carpet the cadillac cts-v
cadillac bulletproof truck hellcat
charger though hellcat charger
yeah that's it first time i started
liking cars it would have been like
maybe back in the days i was growing up
they had the
chargers the daytona chargers the boosie
had one back in the day
and used to ride on dubs floaters
was like oh i gotta buy a car they gotta
be that car my very first car was a
honda accord
it was like a 1993 the same same year i
was born
it caught on fire i'm just driving i had
my
i had my foot in the pedal the pedals to
the floor and
[ __ ] caught on fire had a girl in the
car with me i was embarrassed
i don't miss that car one bit i don't
miss it
don't miss that car at all i got five
cars but i'm a long way from the honda
a hundred percent so that's a wrap i go
by the name of ghana and that was my
10th essentials i appreciate you i
appreciate you
coming through let me show you my 10
essentials shout out to all my fans
check out wanna right now it's out you
know what
[Music]
anytime